Hamas launches hundreds of rockets on
Israeli civilians leading Democrats to
rush to defend Hamas and also Bernie
Sanders Kansas grab socialism i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show all
right a lot to get to today obviously
big events happening in the middle east
a lot of talk about iran's intervention
in the Middle East process which has
been facilitated by you know us flying
pallets of cash over to the Iranian
regime don't worry we'll get to all of
it first no one really has time to go to
the post office you're busy he's got
time for all that traffic parking
lugging all your mail in packages it is
a real hassle which is why you need
stamps calm it's one of the most popular
time-saving tools for small businesses
stamps calm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts you can't even get at the post
office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Post Office to recs
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is that
simple with stamps calm you get five
cents off every first class stamp up to
40% off Priority Mail not to mention
it's a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters stamps calm
it's a no-brainer it's easy time it
saves you money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm
including we here at the daily where we
use stamps calm right now my listeners
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and the
digital scale no long term commitment
just go to stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in Shapiro that is stamps calm and
then enter Shapiro for that special deal
stamps commenter Shapiro we love stamps
calm you will too
I promise I use it in my house as well
by the way stamps calm enter Shapiro
alrighty so over the weekend we got a
fulsome display of what anti-semitism
looks like so it's been really
interesting to watch as various
political players manipulate the issue
of anti-semitism so as to defend certain
parties and not to defend certain
parties here's the deal as I've been
saying for years at this point there are
three types of anti-semitism
there's right-wing white supremacist
anti-semitism those are the white super
those are the people most likely to try
and murder you
I know because someone was arrested last
week for apparently threatening to
murder me this
white supremacists okay number two there
there people on the left the far left
anti-semites who suggest that Israel and
the Jews are behind all world events and
that's why they're so successful they
stand at top of the hierarchy of power
this tends to merge very well with
certain intersectional notions of
politics and that is why you see the far
left making common cause with the third
type of anti-semites this would be
radical Islamist anti-semitism
unfortunately a very popular view among
Muslims in major countries across the
world
okay polls show this this is not a rip
on Islam as a religion there's a rip on
how many many Muslims are practicing
Islam as a religion but the fact is that
there is a radical Islamist
anti-semitism that is dominant in the
Gaza Strip it is dominant in Judea and
Samaria the West Bank it is dominant in
Saudi Arabia and Egypt and Pakistan and
Afghanistan and Iraq and Iran all these
in Turkey all of these places all of
these places anti-semitism is not just
something that is is looked upon with
some sort of says it some sort of apathy
it's looked upon it as something that is
sort of a requisite for a point of entry
hey that is just a reality by poll
numbers okay so here is the issue what
are we here in the West do about
anti-semitism so if you're on the Left
you've had a tendency to overlook
leftist anti-semitism to pretend that it
doesn't exist I've seen it from some
people on the right who try to minimize
the threat of white supremacists
anti-semitism they look at the white
supremacists they say this is a small
number of people so why am I worried
about it and the answer is you're
worried about it because anti-semitism
of any sort is truly evil and these
anti-semites are likely to shoot up
mosques they're likely to shoot up
shoals because very often they're not
just anti-semites they're also people
who hate Muslims as Muslims and want to
shoot up mosques which is why you've
seen white supremacists doing just that
over the past month left-wing
anti-semites will overlook the entirety
of left-wing anti-semitism they will
pretend instead that it is anti Zionism
and this is what you see with Israel so
over the weekend over the last four days
what you've seen is Hamas an actual
terrorist group an evil evil terrorist
group firing hundreds of rockets into
civilian areas in Israel Hamas is an
evil evil organization the Hamas charter
explicitly calls for the destruction of
the State of Israel okay and they call
for the death of Jews outside of Israel
as well the Hamas covenant is not a
document of peace it is obviously a
document of war and anti-semitism and
evil Hamas is a State Department labeled
terrorist group because Hamas is an evil
evil group The Daily Caller has a piece
from a couple of years ago by Jaime
Weinstein over there talking about
things you need to know about Como's
they quote Egyptian Muslim Brotherhood
founder Hassan al-banna in their
charters and quote Israel will exist and
will continue to exist until Islam will
obliterate it just as it obliterated
others before it Kemal says charter
doesn't just stop at Israel Hamas his
Charter says quote the Prophet Allah
bless him and grant him salvation has
said the day of judgment will not come
about until Moslems fight the Jews
killing the Jews when the Jew will hide
behind stones and trees the stones and
trees will say o Muslims o Abdullah
there's a Jew behind me come and kill
him that is a quote from the hadith the
international community might like the
peace process but their Charter says
initiatives and so-called peaceful
solutions and international conferences
are in contradiction to the principles
of the Islamic Resistance movement this
organization also participates in
conspiracy theories about use they say
there is no war going on anywhere
without Jews having their finger in it
they say the Jews were behind the French
Revolution the Communist revolution and
most of the revolutions we hear a heard
and hear about here and there with their
money they formed secret societies all
this is in the Hamas Charter and it's
camasta it is firing hundreds of rockets
into Israel with their money they formed
secret societies such as the Freemasons
Rotary clubs the lions and others in
different parts of the world for the
purpose of sabotaging societies and
achieving Zionist interests a radical
Islamist anti-semitism suggests that
Jews are the nefarious powers behind
everything and you'll noticed also that
what they start doing is they start
conflating Jews and Zionists and this is
how the left grants cover to radical
Islamists as we will see the left simply
suggests that they're not anti-jewish
they're just anti Zionist so sure they
want to wait 6 million Jews off the
planet again sure they want to destroy
the only collective that could be the
biggest and most powerful collective
body of Jews on planet earth but that's
just an anti Zionist thing guys that has
nothing to do with wanting to slaughter
Jews they also say in the Hamas charter
that the Jews control the media they
said that the only solution is jihad
meaning violent jihad not internal
struggle guys
Hamas is an offshoot of the Muslim
Brotherhood they say that they are in
favor of death for the sake of Allah
Hamas of course accuses Israel of being
Nazi they say that the Jews make no
exception for women or children and then
they say the design is Nazi activities
against our people will not last for
long a so this is what Hamas a Hamas as
an evil terrorist group so here is a map
of what it looked like as the rockets
fell across Israel over the weekend
every one of these if you can see this
every one of these red dots every one of
these red pinpoints is a rocket falling
basically it's all of southern Israel
it's everything from stay wrote to
Ashdod to ash Cologne they everything to
Bear Sheva everything across southern
Israel and central Israel is within the
ambit of these Hamas rockets and Kumasi
is deliberately firing them into
civilian areas and they're very excited
about firing them into civilian areas
and for those who don't know what rocket
fire it looks like here is some footage
of the Rockets being fired from Gaza
Hamas is being funded by Iran so they
have new more sophisticated weaponry
many of these Rockets are unguided but a
few of them are in fact guided and here
is what it looks like when your country
imagine your city here in the United
States is being fired on by hundreds of
rockets from just across the border here
is what that looks like
for those who can't see you're looking
at streams of rockets dozens and dozens
of rockets flying up into the air
directed at civilian areas and this is
what this is what Hamas is doing and
they don't care where those land how do
we know we don't carry those land
because one of these Rockets some of
these Rockets historically have fallen
short and fallen into Palestinian areas
over the weekend a Palestinian pregnant
mother and an a and a baby were killed
by a falling
Palestinian rocket the media immediately
jumped to blame the Jews because they by
every aspect of Palestinian propaganda
because if you're covering the
Palestinians in Gaza Strip the only way
they allow you in is if you use their
propaganda they give false Stef's false
death statistics they suggest that
people who are killed are civilians
rather than members of Hamas or members
of Islamic Jihad another evil terrorist
group that works with Hamas in the Gaza
Strip and the together with Hamas forms
the unity government with the
Palestinian Authority in the West Bank
okay so these so they don't care about
any of they don't care about their own
citizens if they cared about their own
citizens they wouldn't be spending tens
millions of dollars building terror
tunnels in order to fight the Israelis
as opposed to you know building up the
area that Israel left in 2005 this is
part of the background that people also
need to know hey this part of Israel
okay
Gaza Strip is not controlled by the
Israelis the Gaza Strip was completely
pulled out from by the Israelis in 2005
so any talk you hear of people talking
about the so called occupation of the
Gaza Strip there are no Jews in the Gaza
Strip in 2005 Ariel Sharon and the Prime
Minister of Israel decided he didn't
want to use Israeli forces to maintain a
small Jewish community in what was
called goosh qatif and so they forcibly
evacuated those Jews meaning Jews took
other Jews out of the Gaza Strip they
handed over all their resources to the
Palestinian Authority the Palestinian
Authority then proceeded to burn down
all of those areas burn them down can
they hand it over a bunch of greenhouses
that grew vegetables seems pretty pretty
innocent right they handed all of that
over to the Palestinian Authority and
the authorities then burned those to the
ground there hasn't been a Jew living in
the Gaza Strip for 14 years and yet this
is still considered quote unquote
occupation by the way in the aftermath
of Israel pulling out of the Gaza Strip
supposedly in order to jumpstart a peace
process to create a separation that
would make Israel safer the Palestinians
immediately elected not the Palestinian
Authority that Israel had handed over
the Gaza Strip to they immediately
elected Hamas an open terrorist group
the Palestinian authorities a terrorist
group - they've just hidden it better
for a while and they originally headed
by Yasser Arafat the Fatah charter still
calls for the extermination of the State
of Israel
they've never they've never actually
publicly agreed that Israel has a right
to exist they've called for a two-state
solution but every time Israel has
offered one they've rejected it
Israel pulled out of this territory and
then this territory has been used as a
staging point to fire rockets at
civilians in Israel not targeting
military targeting of civilians okay so
all these rocks are being fired at
Israel and Israel has something called
the Iron Dome the Iron Dome system is a
system that's been stationed in many of
Israel's major cities and it allows them
to shoot down these short-range rockets
here is what that looks like when it's
happened here's some footage from the
ground so you can see these puffs of
black smoke in the air
okay the puffs of black smoke in the air
that would be the Iron Dome knocking
down the rock
it's now would be important to mention
here that one particular presidential
candidate in the Democratic Party voted
against even funding Israel's Iron Dome
that be bata Aurora 800 rock was one of
eight Congress people who voted against
giving Israel the ability to shoot down
rockets fired at its civilian areas but
shows you where beta o Rourke and many
members of the Democratic Party are now
in a second I'm going to show you the
impact of all of this because there are
four people who are dead in Israel three
Jews and a Bedouin and this I mean in no
country no country would allow this sort
of thing none and no one would be
expected to allow this sort of thing
imagine if Mexico were firing 700
rockets into San Diego there would be no
more Mexico there would not be okay the
United States would immediately invade
and topple the regime in Mexico that's
how this would go how do we know because
after al-qaeda knocked down two of our
buildings in New York we took down two
countries who went we knocked out
Afghanistan we took down the Taliban we
invaded them and we stayed there for
near on 20 years and then in order to
prevent another 9/11 this was the actual
mission we went into Iraq as well so the
United States doesn't tolerate this kind
of crap which is why we live a safe and
secure life here Israel is expected to
tolerate this sort of evil specifically
because the world doesn't care if Jews
get killed so long as those Jews are
being killed by certain people and this
is where the anti-semitism question
comes in if you're only taking seriously
one type of anti-semitism I don't want
to hear a crocodile tears about other
types of anti-semitism if you only care
when a Jew gets killed at the Pittsburgh
Tree of Life by a white supremacist but
you don't get kid but you don't care
when did you get punched in Williamsburg
by a minority or you don't get care or
you don't care if a Jew is killed by a
falling rocket in a civilian area in
Israel don't spare me your spare me your
crocodile tears about anti-semitism
we'll get to that in just a second first
let's talk about how you make your
neighborhood safer rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you'll
get an alert you'll be able to see hear
and speak to them all from your phone
that's thanks to HD video and two-way
audio features on ring devices I love
ring comm I've had ring devices at my
house for years at this point and since
I obviously and very much invested in
person
security and the security of my home I
can't ring I can't recommend ring highly
enough in fact over the weekend there's
another person who is worried about
security I recommended ring to them as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight cam the starter kit
has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home just go to ring comm / Ben that is
ring comm / Ben go check them out right
now make your home safer
it makes your neighborhood safer when
your home is safe or your neighborhood
is safer so go check out ring.com right
now it's great when I'm away from home I
don't have to worry about the safety of
my house because I always know what's
happening thanks to ring go check them
out right now at ring comm / Ben okay so
there is this tendency in the West to
act as though this is everyday in Israel
in Israel thanks to these rocket attacks
there were a million people in Israel
who are living underground a million 1
million people living underground thanks
to these rocket attacks everyone had to
evacuate their homes and people have
died in this here's a picture of the
Bedouins who is killed in Israel when
they're many people were killed in
Israel one of them was a Bedouin this
fellow's name happened to be saeed al
Hamada
he's a 50 year old bedouin because
israel is in fact a diverse country
there are no Jews living in the
Palestinian Authority nor will there be
there are a million and a half non-jews
living in the State of Israel maybe 2
million at this point another person
killed Pinkus pishoosh minh a 21 year
old father of two who was killed Moshe
Gaddy was a 58 year old was killed when
his van was hit by a Hamas rocket and by
the way if Israel did not have quick
response systems then it would have been
a lot worse here for example is a
picture of a kindergarten that was hit
the rocket fell right into the middle of
a kindergarten is a special-needs
kindergarten so Israel specifically
targets terrorists and Hamas
specifically targets special needs
kindergartens but don't worry morally
equivalent according to many in the West
there's a house in Bear Sheva that was
destroyed you can see a picture the it's
video of the of the full destruction of
the house
I mean the house was blown up right the
rocket fell right on top of it thank God
the people inside that house were living
underground when that happened and then
of course there was a burning ambulance
because one of these struck an ambulance
because terrorists don't care
terrorists don't care in a second I'm
gonna show you what it's like to move
why all anti-semitism is basically of a
piece and why it should be treated as a
piece so as I say the same anti-semites
who want to kill Jews in Europe don't
care about Jews getting killed in Israel
the same anti-semites who pretend to
care about white supremacists killings
at the Tree of Life synagogue will
defend Jews being murdered in their beds
in Israel so long as the cause is just
according to some anti-semites Jewish
blood is cheap and so this leads to
horrific and sad situations like this is
this is a video of a Dutch woman heard
this is this Dutch family moved from
Rotterdam to Nahal oz they moved away
from the Netherlands because of the rise
of anti-semitism in the Netherlands rise
in hate crimes many of those hate crimes
committed by radical Muslims they moved
instead to knock all Oz which is in the
south of Israel yesterday their house
was destroyed by a Palestinian terror
rocket watch this video and watch all
the way to the end imagine that this is
your life no I'm not leaving this is my
house that's out is the air raid alarm
there hearing right there is the alarm
goes off and then she charges into her
house and she has to go secure her
family and bring them underground no
country no country should stand for this
certainly not from an evil terrorist
group like Hamas no country should stand
for this so Israel has responded
basically with targeted hits so Israel
responds by killing terrorists
terrorists try to kill as many as
Raley's as possible they don't care
whether it's Arab they don't care
whether it's Jew they don't care whether
its Muslim they don't care about any of
that the only thing they care about is
killing as many as Raley's as possible
because they're a terrorist group and
Israel tries to strike as many specific
targets as it can in fact what you will
see is that the left is lying about this
of course when I say the left I mean
people like Rasheeda to leave in ohon
Omar which we'll get to in a second
they're lying about all of this they're
saying that what touch this off was
indiscriminate Israeli treatment of
Palestinians that is a lie what touched
all of this off is that camasta wrists
were working with quote-unquote protest
groups on the Israeli border to shoot
Israeli soldiers Israel retaliated by
killing some camasta terrorists and
within days they were firing hundreds of
rockets into the center of Israel but
here's an example of is what Israel did
so Israel knocked out hamas financier he
Lagos and terrorists the idea for least
a photo of his burned out car he said we
just targeted Hamad Abdel kouddous a
Gaza and terrorists responsible for
transferring Iranian funds to Hamas and
the Palestinian Islamic Jihad and Gaza
helping fund their rocket fire at
Israelis transferring Iranian money to
Hamas and the pIJ doesn't make you a
businessman it makes you a terrorist
and so they specifically targeted this
particular guy in his car and they hit
him now that's an amazing thing and the
reason that Israel has not been harsher
in dealing with Hamas is specifically
because Hamas knows they know for a fact
that if they put all of their weaponry
in civilian areas that Israel is less
likely to hit them because Israel has a
rule called para Hanushek meaning the
meaning purity of arms that says that
you are specifically Israel is more
humane than any country's military on
planet Earth
with the possible exception of the
American military and maybe even not
that just because the American military
doesn't have to deal with this on
America's borders
hey Israel goes out of its way only to
kill terrorists and conversely
terrorists specifically used civilian
areas of shield so for example here's a
picture of where Hamas has placed one of
their rocket launchers if you can see
this picture what you will see is that
the rocket launcher is placed at the top
of a mosque in a minaret and Israel has
been hesitant hated it why because at
the top of a mosque Islamic Jihad uses
mosques as command and control centers
the IDF said Palestinian Palestinian
Islamic Jihad a terrorist group in Gaza
was using a mosque an all shot the a
densely populated area as a command and
control center terrorists in Gaza used
places of worship for military purposes
we targeted the command and control
center last night the Hamas headquarters
during the last Gaza war was beneath the
hospital because they know that Israel
will not hit the
it'll because they don't want to kill
innocent people there is no moral
equivalence here none anyone who tries
to draw a moral equivalence between the
Israelis are desperately attempting not
to kill Palestinian civilians and the
Palestinian Authority and Hamas and
Islamic Jihad and the people who side
with them and voted for them who are
eager to fire rockets into the center of
civilian areas and who won't even
protect Palestinian civilians who
deliberately put Palestinian civilians
in harm's way who hide behind their own
civilians because they don't want to be
killed because they're cowards anybody
who draws that moral equivalence between
the Israelis who have not only hands it
over without any preconditions the Gaza
Strip to the control of the Palestinians
but also have made repeated concessions
in terms of territory to the
Palestinians over and over and over who
a who no matter in 2008 offered fully 96
percent of all land in Judea and Samaria
in the West Bank most of which is
historic Israel offered 96 percent and
the other 4 percent would be land swaps
so the Palestinians would receive 100
percent of land as well as connections
between Judea and Samaria and the Gaza
Strip as well as East Jerusalem as the
capital of a new Palestinian state and
Malcolm Abbas the head of the
Palestinian Authority walked away from
the table without a counteroffer and
that was only the second to offer in the
last several years Israel has repeatedly
made concessions from Oslo to the White
River Accords to 2001 ahead Barack
offered to walk away who Barak offered
everything and even the Clinton
administration didn't understand why
Yasser Arafat walked away
hey that is demonstrative anybody who
tries to draw a moral equivalence
between a group that open I mean they're
not hiding the ball here from us they
openly stay they want to kill as many
Jews as possible that the Quran calls
for them to do so and that they want
Israel destroyed root and branch
anybody who suggests that their genocide
all anti-jewish Nazi s treatment of Jews
is equivalent with Israel's specific
targeted attempts to kill specific
terrorists in defense of their own
citizenry is morally insane morally
insane and yet what you have seen is
this moral insanity that has conquered
the left the moral insanity not one
Democratic presidential candidate has
spoken about what's happening in Gaza
not 1 0-0
not one I mean that's isn't an
unbelievable statement so you have an
American democratic ally under attack
with hundreds of rockets hundreds of
rockets aimed at civilian areas within
days and not one Democratic presidential
candidate has spoken out about it not a
single one so here's my question
pro-israel people people who just don't
like anti-semitism I'm not saying you
gotta vote Republican what I'm saying is
I don't know how you can vote for this
party I do not know how you can vote for
this party I'm not saying you gotta vote
for Donald Trump maybe I hate Trump fine
but this isn't about that is do you have
the moral courage to recognize what the
Democratic Party is becoming what they
become not one comment from a single
Democratic candidate as a democratic
ally as Israel is put under attack by
hundreds of rockets from an openly
stated anti-semitic terror group and
then I'm supposed to believe you guys
when you are shedding crocodile tears
over come out of POW way or over the
Tree of Life synagogue I'm supposed to
believe the New York Times when the New
York Times sheds those crocodile tears
at the same time that it refuses to take
sides against Hamas yeah you can all go
do something unprincipled to yourselves
in a second I'm gonna show you how the
left has done this but first for a few
weeks now I've been reminding you
Mother's Day is fast approaching its
just days away now so I don't know what
you've been doing but here's the good
news one eight hundred Flowers is here
to help you pick out a gorgeous bouquet
that will show her that she's loved
right now when you order a dozen
multicolored roses for just $29.99 1-800
flowers we'll give you another dozen
plus a vase absolutely free that is 40%
off the original price listen I love
1-800 flowers every time I go out of
town i order my wife a bouquet from
1-800 flowers when she passed her boards
two weeks ago I bought her a bouquet
from 1-800 flowers that's because all of
the roses are just gorgeous I mean
everything that they do is is beautiful
and it lasts the vases are really nice
this gorgeous bouquet of two dozen roses
for Mother's Day and a rainbow of colors
it's a perfect surprise she's guaranteed
to love roses are the perfect way to
surprise all the moms in your life wife
sister grandma these breathtaking roses
from 1-800 flowers they're picked at
their peak they're shipped overnight to
ensure freshness a dozen multicolored
roses for only $29.99 plus another dozen
and a vase for free
it's an amazing offer you have to hurry
it does expire on Friday trust 1-800
flowers to make your mom feel loved
order today from 1-800 flowers calm to
order a dozen extra
Multi colored roses plus an extra
bouquet in a vase for just 2999 but a
1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro
that's 1-800 flowers calm / Shapiro that
awesome offer ends on Friday okay so as
I say I've been sort of darkly hinting
that the left has supported Hamas
through this as I say not a single
Democratic presidential candidate has
even commented on this can you imagine
if England were under attack the UK were
under attack by a terrorist group by
al-qaeda firing 700 rockets into the
heart of London do you think that any of
those Democratic presidential candidates
would be silent there's something to
firt about the Jews there's something
different about this conflict and the
attempt to portray an attack on Jewish
civilians by a terrorist group that
calls for the wiping out of Jews all
over the planet as anything but
anti-semitism demonstrates how leftist
anti-semitism makes common cause with
radical Islamist anti-semitism and again
I don't want to hear your crocodile
tears about Jews getting shot in
synagogues by white supremacist when you
don't give a damn if Jews get shot in
synagogues by Muslim terrorists don't
care so I want to hear from you
you have no moral legitimacy none if you
cannot condemn what is going on right
now
if you can't condemn Hamas or Islamic
Jihad then you got nothing it's amazing
it's amazing to me that people on the
left or even in the Muslim community
would have any trouble condemning this
stuff at all it's incredible to me I
remember a few years back I was on Fox
News and they had on somebody who I
believe from care from the Council on
american-islamic relations which is an
unindicted co-conspirator in the Holy
Land Foundation trial the Holy Land
Foundation was basically a front group
for Hamas raising money for Hamas and
Hezbollah among other terrorist groups
allegedly and the spokesperson for care
was sitting there I said why it can't
you condemned Hamas I mean just
condemned Hamas I think I said will you
condemn the KKK I said of course I'll
condemn the KKK they're garbage and
they're evil why wouldn't I condemn the
KKK this is not difficult like I'm happy
to condemn anybody who's evil but there
is a whole group of people who won't and
those people include people like Linda
Sarsour who you will recall introduced
senator Kirsten Gillibrand at a rally is
a well-respected member of the hardcore
left a head of the women's March a
friend to Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda Talib
and Alexander Ocasio Cortes those
morally despicable fresh
and leaders in the House Linda Sarsour
wrote I am trained in Qingyuan Kenyan
non-violence which is hilarious since
she has campaigned with rasma Oda a
convicted terrorist
Shaz I choose non-violence as a powerful
means to change but I don't have to
choose or justify violence to understand
where it comes from
when oppressed people see no way out we
have to be critical thinkers advocate
and present solutions ok that would be
her making excuses for Hamas terrorists
because Linda Sarsour doesn't care about
terrorism so long as it is directed to
Jews she does not care about it she is
an anti-semite Rashida to leave another
anti-semite so there Sheena to lead
tweets out when will the world stop
dehumanizing our Palestinian people who
just want to be free I was unaware that
wanting to be free allows you to fire
rockets at civilians on the other side
of a border didn't realize that also if
you want to be free maybe you should get
rid of the camasta regime that is
oppressing its own people and spending
tens of millions of dollars on weaponry
to fight Israelis across the border when
they have complete domestic control
inside the Gaza Strip when and I will
make one other note here Rashida Talib
is somebody who has suggested that Jews
have dual loyalty when it comes to
Israel what is this our Palestinian
people business now I don't have a
problem with her using that phrase she's
Palestinian I don't the problem with
that but if you're gonna accuse other
people have dual loyalty lady you might
want to take a look in the mirror if
that's the kind of phraseology that
you're happy using she has headlines
like this and framing it in this way
just feeds into the continued lack of
responsibility on Israel who unjustly
oppressed and target Palestinian
children and families Israel unjustly
targets Palestinian children and
families this is happening in the middle
of a Hamas firestorm directed at
kindergartens directed at ambulances
directed at families and homes and she
is saying oh yeah this is Israel's fault
she's a terrorist apologist Rashidah
Talib and she's a damned anti-semite as
well it is incredible that she's able to
get away with this and not only get away
with this that the Democratic Party will
continue to ignore it these are the same
idiots and moral reprobates who wouldn't
even pass an anti-semitism resolution
naming Ilhan Omar Ted to broaden it out
to include all forms of hate why because
they understand that if they condemn man
to condemn anti-semitism they're
condemning the members of their own
party it's not just
she totally patil Han Omar for herself
when I say she's a terrorist apologist I
mean she actively wrote a letter to a
judge in 2016 asking that Isis recruits
be given a lighter sentence because they
were marginalized communities in the
United States and talk about a lady who
in 2013 in an interview laughed at the
idea that al Qaeda and Hezbollah were
scary and bad so here's what she tweeted
out in the middle of all of this how
many more protesters must be shot
Rockets must be fired and little kids
must be killed until this endless cycle
of violence ends hey the people who were
shot by the Israelis were not protesters
they are they're embedded among
protesters and firing at Israeli
soldiers two Israeli soldiers were
severely wounded and Israel fired back
on people who were shooting at them
how many more rockets must be fired the
only people firing rockets right now
aren't the Hamas jihadis who are trying
to murder Jews in their beds how many
little kids must be killed I don't know
why you ask the Fogel family a family
living in Israel who were slaughtered in
their beds by terrorists and those
terrorists were then were then their
families were rewarded by the
Palestinian Authority and streets were
named after the terrorist who murdered I
kid you not toddlers in their beds
the Fogle family look it up Johanna
Mayer tweets the status quo of
occupation and humanitarian crisis in
Gaza is unsustainable only real justice
can bring about security and lasting
peace I assume by real justice she means
firing rockets to civilians the status
quo of occupation there is no occupation
in the Gaza Strip the only thing that
Israel does is prevent transportation
from Israel to the Gaza Strip and the
only reason they do that is because
Hamas controls the Gaza Strip and has
been using those transportation borders
as a way to attack Israelis and this is
insanity and the Democratic Party not
award nothing nothing what they will do
is they will point to the the be far
left Jews who have no association with
Judaism other than to use it as a cover
for their own anti Israel their own
anti-israel activity and willingness to
cover for anti-semitism
this would include suppose that rabbi
Jill Jacobs who's a rabbi like I'm a
basket like like I'm an NBA player she's
a rabbi like Bernie Sanders is a
capitalist rabbi Jill Jacobs who knows
less about Judaism than the average dog
owned by a Jew
rabbi Joel Jacobs says came
that's not comparing her to a dog that's
comparing her level of knowledge to that
of a non sentient being rabbi Joel
Jacob's rights came out of Shabbat to
more news of needless loss of life
praying for the families of the Israelis
and the Palestinians killed today
and for political leadership with the
courage to seek political non-military
solutions
oh yeah it's really about Israel's
leadership I see I see some making
excuses there Thank You Jill Jacobs
she's the head of a terrible group
called truer and then there's another
one called if not now which is again a
radical anti-israel group and they make
justification for Hamas firing rockets
at civilian areas saying we cannot look
at this in isolation this latest
flare-up is the result of years of
deliberate Israeli political decisions
to keep Gaza on the brink of a
humanitarian crisis really is it that or
is it that Israel has been paying all
the bills in Gaza who do you think pays
for the electricity who do you think
make sure the water keeps on flowing it
ain't come us the only reason that Hamas
continues to function in the Gaza Strip
is because Israel is afraid that if they
knock out come out there will be no one
to pick up the garbage if not now says
the indifference of Israelis Americans
Jews and non-jews alike - this is
appalling
you know it's appalling the fact that
you're making excuse for a terrorist
group but of course if not now is doing
that there's a shocker
there's a shocker you want to know by
the way about the left's willingness to
overlook anti-semitism based on the
identity of the anti-semites all you
have to know is this video so there's a
video of children this isn't this is not
in the Gaza Strip this is not in Judea
and Samaria this is not in Turkey or
Saudi Arabia or Egypt this is in
Philadelphia there's a tape of kids in
Philadelphia and this tape of kids in
Philadelphia chanting in Arabic about
taking back all Aqsa this would be the
Temple Mount his store the holiest spot
in Judaism by but by the way Israel has
given up control of the of the Temple
Mount effectively to the Islamic walk
which is why if you're a Jew you can't
go up there and say and say people have
to kill them you can't actually go up
there and say a psalm if you say a psalm
on the Temple Mount you could get
arrested if you're a Jew if you're
Muslim you just go to mosque there in
any case here are a bunch of Muslim kids
in the United States funded by the
Muslim Muslim American Society and these
kids are chanting rebels rebels rebels
chopped off
their heads in Philadelphia in
Philadelphia in the United States
Lauria steeds call us and lead us on to
caste leading to the al-aqsa mosque we
will defend the land of divine guidance
with our bodies we will chop off their
heads we will liberate the sorrowful and
exalted al-aqsa mosque will lead the
army of Allah fulfilling his promise and
we will subject them to eternal torture
these are kids in Philadelphia funded by
the Muslim American Society the Muslim
American Society said we'll look into it
but we're embarrassed this got out yeah
I'm sure you're embarrassed this got out
so question didn't we have months
literally months of coverage of the
Covington Catholic kids for standing
there wearing Magga hats months of
coverage and that was a Catholic school
right because Catholics are bad we have
heard from the mainstream media this is
a Muslim school have you heard about
this anywhere was it on CNN was it on
MSNBC did anyone cover it were there any
questions asked about how the Muslim
American society funded this particular
school or what they're doing to prevent
this sort of indoctrination was there
any question about you know maybe
looking into some of the other schools
funded by the Muslim American Society to
see what else they are teaching which
textbooks they are using if they're
funded by Wahhabist who are pushing a
certain agenda no of course we're not
allowed to ask those questions if we do
that's Islamophobia we'll just ignore
this we'll pretend it doesn't exist
if you ignore anti-semitism being
preached to eight-year-olds those kids
are maybe six maybe seven maybe eight
years old in this video in the United
States you don't care about that because
the only sort of anti-semitism you care
about is the white supremacists then you
don't care about anti-semitism what you
really care about is using anti-semitism
as a political tool to attack their
political opponents in which case I have
no interest in your opinions about
anti-semitism or frankly about anything
else because this is not just a question
of Jew hatred it's a question of basic
morality you think if you can't condemn
one type of anti-semitism because you're
too politically invested in the outcome
then you're bad person you have a moral
shortcoming you'll get some more of this
in just a second I'll show you how the
left is is sloughing off anti-semitism
depending on the source first Mother's
Day is coming up there's absolutely
nothing most of us wouldn't do to make
sure the special moms in our life are
happy Sherri's Berry has special
Mother's Day berries designed just for
Mom they're topped with chocolate chips
pink shimmer sugar and swizzles you
choose your delivery
to ensure mom gets your gift of Sherry's
berries exactly when you want her to
your satisfaction it's always guaranteed
Sherry's bears that let me just say the
chocolates for Sherry's berries the
caramels like everything let's save a
lot of kosher products so I have a lot
of these things oh my goodness and their
products are just delicious
if you are looking forward to the best
sweets you can possibly buy you need to
visit berries calm today to order those
freshly dipped strawberries starting at
$19.99 for the moms in your life to make
mom really happy you can double the
berries for just ten bucks more Mother's
Day is Sunday May 12th so visit berries
calm that's BER RI es calm click on the
microphone in the upper right corner
enter my code Ben show that's berries
calm click on the microphone code Ben
show go check it out right now berries
calm I can tell you when I get cherries
berries and I bring it home my wife is
super happy I promise you the mom and
your life will be too that's berry
SATCOM click on that microphone code
bench okay in just a second I'm going to
show you how there are people who are
willing to politically overlook
anti-semitism so long as it is
convenient for them to do so first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire.com go to daily we're calm for
$9.99 a month you get a subscription to
this to daily where you get the rest of
the show live you get the rest of Andrew
Klavan show live Matt Walsh's show live
Michael Moses show live you also get two
additional hours of my show every day
and we have fantastic guests last week
secretary Pompeo senator Ted Cruz we
have we have people from Israel who
gonna be stopping by a little bit later
today to give you the lowdown on what
exactly is going on there have all sorts
of good stuff happening later every day
every we basically do two shows a day
for you but you can only get that on
demand when your ass daily wire
subscriber for 99 bucks a year you also
get this the greatest in all beverage
vessels the leftist cheers hot or cold
tumbler look upon it it's incredible you
will love it so go get that right now
and also make sure you subscribe to
YouTube and iTunes you can get our
Sundays special when your subscriber
then you also get that on Saturday so
this week you could have seen my
interview with nikki Haley on Saturday
as opposed to on Sunday even so check
out YouTube on iTunes
we were last month the second most
listened-to podcast of all podcasts in
the United States helped us make a
number one this month go check us out at
YouTube or iTunes we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
you
so as I say there is there is a tendency
on the part of many on the left to
pretend that what is happening in Israel
is not actually happening in Israel that
anti-zionism is not anti-semitism that
wanting to destroy the State of Israel
and kill every civilian inside it that
really it's not Jew hatred it's just
it's just a political difference really
it's just a political difference that
people are having
and if anti-semitism comes from the left
side of the out it's not anti-semitism
at all
it's just political differences within
Netanyahu government weird because I
would saw the same sort of coverage when
it was a Hutu Olmert who's on the left
when I was a hoot Barak who is on the
Left amazing
weirdly consistent but as I say there
are folks on the Left who are more than
willing to overlook anti-semitism so
long as that anti-semitism is coming
from radical Islamist because in the
intersectional worldview of the left
Muslims are more victimized than Jews
and Jews are more successful than
Muslims and therefore Jews must have
victimized Muslims and therefore
anti-semitism directed from at Jews by
Muslims by radical Islamists that sort
of anti-semitism is justified on
intersectional grounds and then you've
got people on the left you say well you
know if we're anti-israel and we decide
to print something openly anti-semitic
you're gonna have to forgive us I mean
it's easy to get mixed up here's Irian
Carmen is a CNN contributor explaining
on CNN's reliable sources that we're all
paying too much attention to the New
York Times his cartoon you know that
openly anti-semitic cartoon that they
printed a couple of weeks ago that had
the face of Benjamin Netanyahu on a dog
and a Jewish star collar around his neck
leading a blind Donald Trump wearing a
yarmulke a fat blind donald trump
wearing a yarmulke says why are we
paying attention to that sort of stuff
no I know I'm sure Irene Carmen would
say exactly the same thing had it been a
cartoon about say a Muslim leader
leading president Trump around the neck
I'm sure would have been the exact same
thing using every Muslim stereotype in
the book I'm sure that that would have
been fine with the reincarnating that
we're all paying too much attention to
the New York Times his anti-semitic
cartoon I am an Israeli citizen I was
born in Israel I'm fourth generation of
Zionists and my family I thought that
the cartoon was offensive but I also
thought that the attention paid to it
was disproportionate beyond folks like
us reporting on what happened which is
important I also saw it kind of being
cynically exploited to
the subject from the fact that for
example just over a week ago somebody
took up arms and entered a synagogue in
California and killed somebody I know
that a lot of people seized on this who
already have an agenda because they want
to discredit the New York Times and I
think the New York Times responded
adequately and we need to see this in
proportion okay so notice how what she's
doing there is directing away from the
New York Times and back toward the white
supremacist shooting Ana kebab Poway why
can't both be true
why can't anti-semitism from the New
York Times be bad and also white
supremacists anti-semitism is bad why
are people having a tough time with this
this is not particularly tough now in a
second I want to show you a couple on
play for you a couple of pieces of audio
that demonstrate the moral difference
between one side and the other in what
is happening in Israel and the endemic
anti-semitism that is happening inside
the Gaza Strip and the West Bank and yet
again the media pretending many and the
media pretending that there is a moral
equivalence okay so the to to ignore the
moral components of what is happening in
Israel right now is to blind yourself to
reality dennis prager my friend uses a
quick thought experiment to illustrate
the difference between the Israelis and
the Palestinian leadership and and by
the way many of the Palestinian folks
who voted for Hamas right now they
haven't had a vote in the Gaza Strip
since 2006 but when they were allowed to
vote they voted for Hamas before that
they voted for the Palestinian Authority
I would hope that the Palestinians would
would now elect seek to elect a
government that was willing to make some
sort of deal so all of this can come to
the end do you think that the Israelis
desperately want all of their kids to be
drafted into the army serve four years
under danger of death in military
uniform do you think that's really what
they want to do Golda Meir said this a
long time ago there will only be peace
when the Palestinians love their
children more than they hate ours this
is effectively correct well it's it's
pretty amazing if you want to see the
difference between the two sides so
yesterday million people hiding a bomb
shelters the vast majority of them Jews
in a Jewish state which by the way is
amazing isn't that an amazing statement
it used to be the Jews were grouped into
ghettos now Jews in their own state are
being told that they have to go
underground who simply preserve their
lives but this is Jews I mean it's
frankly this is reminiscent of many
scenes from Jewish history in which Jews
were trying to drive hope from some
pretty hopeless
terrible circumstances Jews driven
underground in a bomb shelter a rabbi
found a couple that was supposed to be
married that day and so just performed
the wedding in sunder Hopa inside the
bomb shelter that's what was happening
in Israel here is what was happening in
in the Gaza Strip so as these rockets
were falling as the rockets were falling
here is what Palestinians many
Palestinians were doing inside the Gaza
Strip chanting shouting cheering very
excited
very excited as the Rockets are fired
they're cheering as the Rockets are
fired into Israel how many Israelis were
out there cheering as Israel was firing
rockets at terrorists none you can't
find any video of it anywhere why
because it doesn't exist
Israelis are upset that they have to be
involved in this war many Palestinians
are overjoyed that Jews are in danger of
death in civilian areas that is just a
reality of the situation as I mentioned
Dennis Prager so Dennis Prager thought
experiment is this if the Jews put down
all their guns tomorrow what would
happen we all know the answer if the
Jews put down all their guns if they
disarmed tomorrow there would be no more
Israel the Jews would simply be
destroyed okay the the Palestinians
their allies would walk right in and
kill everyone how do we know this
because the because the Arab countries
surrounding Israel tried to do it in
1948 they try to do it in 1956 they
tried to do it in 1967 they tried to do
it in 1973 they tried to do it in 1981
1982 during the Lebanon War they've
tried to do it during the Gaza war
they've tried it this is not a thought
experienced in ian's or to put down
their guns tomorrow and make peace the
next day there will be a Palestinian
state the next day the this is not the
fact that people try to draw moral
equivalences is simply a sign of moral
ignorance at best and moral evil at
worst now there's a video that I didn't
end up showing I referenced it on Yom
Hashoah so last week was Yom Hashoah the
Holocaust Remembrance Day and in order
to understand what Israel is I think you
have to understand - video so number one
you have to understand the video that we
showed and played a little bit earlier
on in the program of the woman from
Netherlands who moved with her family
from the Netherlands to Israel
specifically because Europe is becoming
unlivable for Jews and so Israel has
become a safe haven for many Jews who
are seeking a safe place to live the
second video you have to see is this one
so this video is from Yamaha shots this
is Holocaust Remembrance Day and there's
an L all plain L all as the Israeli
national airline and the o L plane was
flying over Germany over Berlin the
pilot got up and announced to the plane
in Hebrew that a year before he'd done
this he said that on Yom Hashoah he
tells the plane his story his story is
that all of his grandparents all four
grandparents were slaughtered in the
concentration
by the Germans and he said and if my
grandparents could be alive today
to see a plane with a Jewish star flying
over Berlin then the then I can't
imagine what they would think and then
he begins to sing and the song that he
is singing is a very famous Hebrew song
the translation is the world is a very
narrow bridge and the important thing is
to not be afraid and here is what the
end the entire plane begins singing this
is what that sounds like
[Music]
as the entire plane singing because
omni's - Alki
okay the Jews are going to live through
this they will and it doesn't matter if
you're an anti-semite it doesn't matter
if you're gonna make excuses for
anti-semites it does it the Jews will
continue to live because the Jews have
always continued to live the question is
not about the Jews the question is about
you and I'm this is whether you are Jew
or not Jew it doesn't matter the
question is what sort of Jew hatred are
you willing to stand for what sort of
moral evil are you willing to stand for
in order to protect your own political
hide and protect your own political side
and I don't care whether you do or
whether your non Jew in this question I
mean the fact is that US Jews are
significantly more likely than us
Christians to say the president Trump
for example favors the Israelis too much
this has nothing to do with any sort of
ethnic attachment here if you're a moral
human being this is a moral conflict and
if you are willing to overlook
anti-semitism among one group because
you're afraid that if you don't that you
will alienate your intersectional base
as the Democrats apparently are if
you're willing to do that then you
deserve whatever moral shellac and you
take the it's it's deeply disturbing
forget about as a Jew as an American as
an American it is deeply disturbing to
watch many members of the public on all
sides of the political aisle say that
certain types of hatred are okay based
on the person doing the hating and I
will say that it is far more mainstream
on the left and then on the right these
days and it's you think that as a
conservative this is not a politically
motivated thing I'm not saying this
because I want conservatives to win I'm
saying this because I want decency to
win and want decency to win and if you
can't condemn if you can't have one
Democratic presidential candidate come
forward and say a thing about come on
the only Democrat I've seen who said
nothing is Kyrsten Sinema
the moderate senator from Arizona she's
the only one not a single other Democrat
has said anything about this well then
when when Jews get shot in a synagogue
spare me your thoughts we all know what
you think because the fact is that
anti-semites all over the world have no
problem lumping all Jews together and if
you are willing to grant them cover to
do so based on your own political
convenience you're providing cover for
anti-semites it's as simple as that okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today so this was pretty hilarious
actually so there was a so that there
was a Democratic Senatorial Campaign
Committee tweet they put out there it
was a poll and the poll was a was a poll
on whether you would like to see more
justices like justice Cavanaugh or more
like Justice Ginsburg and here's the
problem Twitter guys you do this and
you're gonna get trolled they got
trolled so hard 71% said justice
Cavanaugh and the Senate Democrats had
to pull down the tweet which is in and
of itself pretty hilarious okay other
things that I like today I have to admit
that Bernie Sanders trying to suggest
that he can't explain his view of
socialism is pretty hilarious so Bernie
Sanders was asked about his view of
socialism and he said he can't describe
it he was asked by Jonathan Karl at ABC
he said I can't describe it it's too
complex for me to describe very quickly
really because I can do free markets in
like a sentence every human being is in
control of their labor boom done wow
that's hard here's Bernie Sanders not
being able to sum up socialism Trump
seems to want to run against you and
certainly he wants to run and
Republicans want to run against
socialism okay oh is it time for you to
disavow that that label the problem is
and on a television interview it's hard
for me to describe in depth what we mean
by that when Social Security was created
what did the Republicans call it called
socialism anytime you do things for the
people and you stand up to the wealthy
and powerful
you'll be labelled this that and the
other thing label you and but all of the
issues that we are talking about these
are ideas that in one form or another
are in fact supported by the American
people okay so this is him again trying
to run away from the consequences of his
own philosophy
the truth is that Bernie Sanders still
has not condemned what is going on
really in Venezuela he's been
effectively silent about all of that so
it is odd if you're a socialist and you
like Norway why are you having trouble
condemning Venezuela why
seems kind
weird right okay but I think a lot of
this is I think a lot of the the truth
is coming out here's a video of
protesters at the Venezuelan embassy
they're protesting against people who
were upset with Nicolas Maduro the evil
socialist dictator of Venezuela they
protested by blasting a Paul Robeson
version of the Soviet national anthem
through the speakers I think it's pretty
obvious where a lot of these folks stand
[Music]
they're inside the embassy and blasting
out audio of the Soviet national anthem
well at least the masks are coming off
at least the masks are coming off okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
so the thing that I hate number one took
Cory Booker who is a desperate political
candidate trying to gain attention he is
he's channeling Joe Biden when he says
this there's this tendency on the left
to equate paying high taxes with being
more patriotic which really does raise
the question if you want to be more
patriotic you guys you can just give
more money to the government like
anytime you want
no one's stopping Cory Booker from doing
it here's cory booker saying don't worry
people won't mind paying higher taxes
because they're patriotic and i mean
that means that if you're the most
patriotic presumably you'd give all your
money to the government that would be
like the super highest form of
patriotism right now be amazing
here's cory booker doing that routine
what do you say to somebody who says
yeah I'm not crazy about Trump but the
economy has done so much better and
Republicans keep telling me the
Democratic nominee is gonna raise my
taxes and he is talking about raising
taxes so that might hurt the economy
that might hurt my bottom line what's
the counter-argument to that look I
think that we live in a nation with far
more patriotism than people are
expressing what I mean by that is folks
want the best for their country and they
know that if your family doesn't have a
great public school for your kid if your
family does not have great access to
health care then we all are suffering as
a result of that and often creating
greater costs oh so that's it so if
you're more patriotic you pay higher
taxes the ultimate form of patriotism is
to give all your resources to the
government I would assume so communism
is the highest form of patriotism great
thanks Cory Booker really appreciate it
it's great when you can avoid the
consequences of your own policy cuz
Tapper asks him an efficiency question
right he says a lot of people worried it
might sink the economy and Booker's like
well if they're patriotic they shouldn't
worry about that okay man if your
patriotic give all your rights to the
government it seems like a scary way to
go
now speaking of scary ways to go Kamala
Harris is now doing this routine
everybody on the Left is doing this
routine where they kowtow to the silly
idea that the Georgia gubernatorial race
was actually won by Stacey Abrams we've
seen Hillary Clinton do this now we've
seen Camille Harris do this here she is
saying that voter fraud is behind every
election it's it's so funny the
Democrats were correct in 2016 where
they said that if Donald Trump didn't
accept the results of the election it
would be dangerous
from the country I said that's true
that's true if we all believe that then
our elections are rigged it's gonna be
very difficult for us to live in a
democratic republic and yet Democrats
are doing this every single day on the
campaign trail and doing it along racial
lines suggesting that black people are
being dispossessed at the polls which by
percentage is not true at all
black people were wildly
over-represented at the polls in both
2008 and 2012 and they've been evenly
represented by percentage of the
population at least since 2008 but
here's Camilla Harris promoting that lie
without voter suppression Stacey Abrams
would be the governor of Georgia lie
that is a lie that is a lie as well
so basically we've never lost an
election according to Camilla Harris
Democrats have won every election and
yet we hear about how dangerous it is
Donald Trump's a dangerous man this is a
very very bad development for the
Republic and Democrats are engaging in
it so spare me your sanctimony about
President Trump breaking our systems of
government when you're suggesting that
every election you lost was unjustly
lost Hillary Clinton won Andrew Gilliam
won Stacey Abrams won I'm sure you care
deeply about the institutions of
democracy all right we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
the ben shapiro show so we will see you
then i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show freshman congresswoman
alexandria Ocasio cortez Rashidah Talib
and Alon Omar proved the age-old maxim
at bottom all political problems are
theological problems we will examine the
politics of religion and religion of
politics from Palestinian rockets to
Pennsylvania mosques and gospel hymns
for the green new deal check it out at
daily wire calm